Covid-19 has encouraged many of us
to look at how we might optimise
our immune responses,
through supplements or superfoods.
But is it even possible to alter how
the body responds to disease
through an immune-boosting pill
or by eating blueberries?
And what about the people
who take it even further?
The biohackers experimenting
with procedures such as
faecal transplants -
basically taking someone
else's poo as a medicine
in an attempt to cure
a range of ills.
Dangerous experimentation
or smart science?
The immune system is part
of an interconnected system,
running all the way through our body.
Involving all our tissues,
from our skin,
all the way through to our toes.
And in fact, the gut has one
of the largest resident populations
of immune cells in our body.
Most of the body's immune cells are
found in the lining of the intestine,
and the microbes in our gut
play a crucial role
in keeping those immune cells
of our body healthy.
And they do that by providing
the key chemical signals
that they get once they digest
the good foods that we eat.
So a healthy gut microbiome
is absolutely critical
to a healthy immune system.
The immune system is considered
to be an organ.
But unlike ever other organ
in your body,
it's one where components
of the system
can migrate around the body.
You don't expect that with cells
from your lungs,
from your spleen,
or any other solid organ.
But the beauty of
the immune system
is it has a property
of immuno-surveillance.
Immunological surveillance is when
the cells of the immune system
come together to coordinate
a response to an external threat
such as disease.
For example, your lymph nodes,
the glands that swell up
when you are sick,
are a sign of your immune
system at work.
We often hear messages encouraging
us to boost our immune system.
So, could we just take a pill
to do that?
When you do meet
an infectious threat,
our immune response
has to react quickly -
to contain the threat
and eradicate it.
And you don't want it to stay on,
because if it says on, it's damaging.
And that is what happens in allergy
and autoimmune disease,
which are over-reactivity
of the immune response.
So there is no wonder pill that is
going to restore and boost one part
of the immune response
to help us be super-powered,
because it's all so interconnected,
and the risks of getting it wrong
are really quite dramatic.
So, instead of boosting
our immune system,
we should focus on supporting it.
Everything that we know already
which is good for our health
will also benefit our immune system.
More exercise,
taken at regular intervals,
has been shown to boost
your immune function.
That's been shown,
and that's published data.
Unfortunately, the modern lifestyle
is not very good
for our immune system.
Our diets of convenience foods
and fatty foods
that are low in fibre
alongside sedentary lifestyles
with little exercise,
high stress and not too much sleep -
too much screen time.
All of these combine
to make our immune response
not work as it should.
Getting enough sleep
and reducing stress
can help our immune system
operate at an optimal level.
And even though one blueberry
won't work miracles,
getting a variety of the right foods,
is very important.
To help your immunity you need
to be feeding up your gut microbes,
and the best way to do this
is to make them more diverse -
give them more species.
And I recommend 30 different
types of plant a week,
which gives you all
the fibre you should need.
Secondly, you should pick plants
to eat that are high in polyphenols.
These are the chemicals that
are naturally found in plants
that are actually rocket fuel
for your gut microbes.
So things like
brightly coloured berries,
strong flavours like coffee beans,
dark chocolate and even red wine
contain polyphenols.
So, if what you eat and your gut is
so important for your immune system,
why are some people transplanting
other people's poo
into their own stomachs?
Faecal microbial transplant
or, colloquially, a poo transplant,
is taking a sample of a stool
from a normal person
and putting it into someone
who is unwell.
This has been done
for several decades
for very bad infections of the bowel,
like Clostridium difficile,
and it cures 90% of people.
And it's been since started to be
used in a number of other conditions.
This is a fascinating area
of research,
but definitely not to be tried
at home, says Tim.
I think this is an exciting
new form of therapy,
but it's always best to do this
within the confines
of a medical clinic,
where things can be supervised
and the risk of side effects
or infection is extremely low.
There are some people who take risks
and do do it at home,
and those risks will be
multiplied considerably.
There's a lot of hype about
faecal transplants,
and you mustn't believe people who
say that it works with everything,
in everybody, it certainly doesn't,
and there are many failures
in clinical trials.
One of the ways we can
effectively and safely manipulate
our immune responses
is through vaccination.
What a vaccine is doing
is essentially giving you
the parts of the germ that will
stimulate the immune response,
without actually getting
the full blown infection.
Another thing that we can do,
is actually try to switch
the immune response off.
For some diseases we don't want
a powerful immune response,
because that's what's causing
the damage.
This is exactly what's done in
diseases like rheumatoid arthritis,
multiple sclerosis,
or is also being investigated
in infections like Covid.
The good news is, whilst there's
no one magic pill we can take
to boost our immune response,
the more scientists learn about
how our immune system works,
the more they can develop
new drug treatments and therapies
to combat a wide range of diseases.
The knowledge of science is actually
leading to all sorts of wonderful
new possibilities to help treat us
and win the war against infection.